so the GTX 1060 6 GB cards have been
available for a while now but the
founders Edition version that we
reviewed back when they launched has all
but disappeared from the market at this
point and while finding a non-reference
card can also be difficult looking at
this gigabyte one for instance it's out
of stock at newegg.com and in low stock
on Amazon at least you can get them so
how do they compare to the founders
edition cards and how do they stack up
against the competition on amd's side
let's find
[Music]
out freshbooks is the super simple
invoicing solution that lets you get
organized save time and get paid faster
click now to try it for free starting
with the physical Hardware that gigabyte
has strapped on this GTX 1060 G1 gaming
6 GB Edition card it comes with dual
wind forc 90mm fans which have striped
blades and unique curves that claim they
will increase air flow by 23% when they
spin of fanless mode is included along
with a bright don't worry I'm not dead
LED unusually however they spin in
different directions seriously if you
look at the card without the fan
spinning you'll see that the left fan
Scoops to the left and the right fan
Scoops to the right theoretically this
results in a reduction of air turbulence
as they both push air out the top of the
card to together does it feel like to
anyone else that every year there's some
new way to just put fans on a graphics
card the heat sink they sit on features
two direct touch copper heat pipes which
also claim a vague 29% Improvement
bringing us to the Real Results a pretty
impressive 61° C in a room temperature
of about 25° all while the card was
pushing our Crisis 3 Skybox stair test
and running at 1987 MHz which is 140 MHz
above o the advertised boost clock okay
that's actually pretty sweet but who
cares about speed where's the RGB
lighting never fear the aforementioned
fan stop LED is actually RGB along with
the gigabyte logo just to the left of it
but while the decision to include this
was great and all it does feel a little
odd when paired with the Striking orange
accents on the card itself yes these are
near the fans and therefore will be out
of sight in most cases but it feels like
they were kind of a oversight in regards
to power the G1 comes with a 6+1
powerphase design compared to the
reference 3+1 setup and it has this cool
Smart LED indicator I've seen power
cable indicators in the past that just
illuminate if you have a cable plugged
in this one however flashes if there's
an issue with your power supply or
illuminates if the cable is unplugged
which makes more sense to me for output
it comes with a standard setup for a GTX
1060 which is one dual link DVI d one
HDMI 2.0b and three display port 1.4
connectors which can support up to 8K at
60 HZ although good luck gaming at that
resolution and now if you want to learn
more about the GP 106 chip that is
inside of this GPU check up here for our
launch video on the 1060 and Skip to
about 1 minute and 7 seconds and if you
want to see our overview of the new
software features that were released
with the Pascal architecture like the
surprisingly interesting screenshot tool
named anel and some new VR Works
features check out this GTX 1080 review
and Skip to about 1 minute and 50
seconds anyways let's move right onto
performance I tested gigabyte's G1
gaming 1066 GB against a reference
Founders Edition 6 GB card its bigger
brother the GTX 1070 in an EVGA
superclocked variant and the main
competition from the other side the
rx480 unfortunately I couldn't test it
against the reason that I keep calling
it a 1066 GB the recently released
Nvidia 3 GB GTX 1060 Nvidia surprised
everyone with that and as we don't have
one of those in office yet I was not
able to do anything with it so stay
tuned for that it's able to push well
over 60 frames per second in every title
we tested with maximum presets at 1080p
which Nvidia has been pretty clear as
the target resolution for this card and
with those settings everything looked
nice and crispy it beat out it's more
expensive Founders Edition cousin
although it's not too surprising in as
it ran about 127 MHz faster when under
load in our Crisis 3 Skybox stair test
thanks to GPU boost and its better
cooler and board design the more
interesting story here is how it trades
blows with the rx480 it wins by a
considerable amount in crisis three and
Rise of the Tomb Raider and surprisingly
manages a win in ashes of the
singularity as well but when we take a
look at doom and Hitman there's a shift
in the balance for power for Hitman the
gigabyte 1060 wins in direct X1 but
loses in directx12 despite both of them
gaining overall performance then moving
to Doom Vulcan and asynchronous compute
being applied it's not even a fair
contest the rx480 wins by a massive 20%
so the story continues to be what it has
been nvidia's Pascal gpus are fast and
gigabyte's G1 gaming variant of the 1066
GB card is a solid option with great
Cooling and low noise floor it even
managed to stay relatively quiet under
heavy Lo but this seems to be more of an
architectural battle at this point
instead of the crazy aftermarket cooler
Showdown that we saw with the 700 900
series it will be interesting to see how
each side holds up in about a year as
more and more games keep on coming out
with Vulcan and directx12 support and
when AMD hopefully has some kind of
response to nvidia's higher-end
cards do you hate weird privacy issues
that come along with traveling sitting
on open Wi-Fi networks at like Starbucks
and stuff maybe you should try tunnel
bear with tunnel bear turned on your
Wi-Fi connection is secured and your
online privacy is kept well private this
includes from your internet provider
advertisers hackers anyone looking to
track and or profit from your data
tunnel bear has a top rated privacy
policy and does not log your activity
which is good you can try for free with
500 megabytes and no credit card
required and if you choose to get a year
of unlimited data you can save 10% by
going to Tunnel bear.com
SLT anyways guys thanks for watching hit
that like button if you liked it
subscribe all that kind of stuff if you
hated it hit the dislike button um check
out this video to see our previous 1060
video on the founders Edition that I
referenced earlier check the link the
video description down below to buy
stuff at Amazon or get a cool t-shirt
that isn't this one and I said that for
the first time while wearing a lonus
techtips logoed shirt Get Wrecked this
is for pack we're going there tomorrow
so I'm going to end the video now
because I think I said everything that I
have to okay